that previous [ __ ] off I can't play we
came all the way to my birthday party
just to give me this old crap she's just
a little louder
I should like do something to him Oh
would you do with witches you burned
them
I don't tell I didn't what to do no one
knows all static a line in a cage we're
tied together did did he do that to you
no well who did that it's the monsters
what and the fire bad Jodie
if this wasn't an exercise you'd be dead
by now you'd be a little you big mouth
oh he controlled her welcome to the
agency it's like you're 80 unacceptable
now sugar risk mine is parapa welcome to
another episode of beyond to soulless we
just finished our CIA montage and it
says we're gonna get hunted that sounds
fun so we're on a train huh in the
middle of the woods huh
copy rice of nightmares huh send one
remember that game those games
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah okay whoa are we out
this is awesome
seriously I love the a lot of the game
looks like you gotta appreciate it
so Aidan chills out chill out outside
can we [ __ ] with [ __ ] whoopsie oopsie
enough I didn't I was I didn't let me
sleep I thought for sure was Aidan now I
feel really awkward all right well let's
[ __ ] around with some hey how you doing
sir
it'd be a shame if someone pulled your
arm I'm twisting side you have
superpowers but you're using it to [ __ ]
with people I guess that makes me a
villain huh what are we supposed to do
and I can't exit
I didn't stop that I'm sorry this is
really funny
hey if you can do it too you would
appreciate it okay fine so boring
geez what am I supposed what is a ghost
supposed to host [ __ ] that rhymes my god
I'm a genius
so I think we're back in Crescent tine
when she were escaping from the cat's in
the beginning who took my magazine
that's all we're gonna pick up my
magazine now anything where happens I'd
be really angry that's right yeah ain't
nobody [ __ ] with me my magazine mm-hmm
yeah game looks super cool I'm Way more
interested in it when it's like this I
think the first two episodes were like
to introduce a setting and story and
interactivity
I hope it will pick up from this point
it seems like it at least that train is
so awesome was it doing it oh [ __ ] the
cops are they coming up we got to wake
her up gotta use my bottle powers Wow
you're welcome you're welcome
Hey look I told you that just trying to
look out for you okay you look the
Cape's a he see you not see now you're
not so angry are you
do they enter the Train
Oh al can we man I heard your seat
please
I just really need to go to the bathroom
I ate a lot to touch a fast day no push
okay
I'm sorry that keep running girl geez
crazy Kip got it please [ __ ] Oh up up
up up up there we go
nothing nothing I'm just dancing
I have explosive diarrhea that's nothing
to joke about
must make it to the bathroom
Oh oh no my jacket how dare why'd she
keep turning around Oh [ __ ] main
character from heavy rain keep going
my exit here
oh [ __ ] I can or shed oh [ __ ]
oh oh oh this is too intense for me I
don't like this okay God oh it's just
when I'm stressed he's crazy
don't touch me
no no no oh damn
she's depends she's sometimes man girl
you cray you creo que how is she not
falling off where's she gonna go anyway
you have to jump off right man Jodi's
crazy
karate chop [ __ ] okay don't touch me
bro
yeah that's fast it's very cool look at
this awesome
I love it oh [ __ ] oh snap gotta keep
movin huh
gotta keep sighing OH hope there's not a
tunnel
Oh
fighting time ha ha
the action sequences are actually kind
of cool this is kind of hard to tell
what the [ __ ] they're in which direction
the pole see that looked like it was
coming from below but it wasn't carotid
knee shot that was not a knee unless my
knees and my elbow
you never know these things do you
that's badass
so is this part of Eden's power because
she's [ __ ] bad as it fighting stop
karate shopping
you're gonna jump girl oh here we go
you're never catching me what am i doing
what am i doing why am i focusing on the
rest what what is this but focus on the
ass hey do what I do
so my superhero power is to focus on
asses
I'm a super power hero all along okay we
got to keep going
the dogs are coming excuse me the heavy
breathing it's on me by Edgar Edgar you
gotta go I'm recording okay no you can't
be in my videos you attention [ __ ] all
right we gotta get out of here before
they come back I didn't say anything but
yeah you keep talking to yourself
reminds me of Alan Wake huh huh pants
you should play I don't know I already
played it okay
good game that it looks like a spaceship
hey don't sway it's not good
don't eat your head that girl yeah
even though it's like very little
interactivity between these sequences or
whatever you call it it is actually kind
of cool to control and these when you're
fighting jumping over lot entries is not
that great I don't know I'm just that's
my opinion
but hey I'm not failing at it I think
that deserves some recognition
considering how angry you both get if
I'd fail that was not a joke I feel
terrible
oh [ __ ] yeah I really don't want to get
caught like I think I think it's like
heavy rain if you get caught it actually
changes the story's out I really don't
want to [ __ ] up
hey don't shoot me I'm innocent I think
not sure what I did actually
I hate that once they make you clay it's
like geez couldn't you have come up with
something at what am I going how doesn't
even be gotten how shed there's light
some of that we shouldn't go that Kali
okay yep
yep
my cab Eden just kill everyone like last
time it was awesome
I'm just saying I don't like I meant
killing solves a lot of problems that's
all I'm gonna say and it's illegal I
guess that's my interval after all
oh [ __ ] doggies that's not good
hey I'm hey I'm not hurting dogs that's
against my principles
princey but this if this sticks hurts
them then I don't take no responsibility
it's a stick
I'm sorry uh-huh uh sorry oh [ __ ]
she's brutal Oh finish him oh that's my
stick don't you dare touch [ __ ]
badass how could she be so badass
hey I don't catch dogs I'm sorry it's a
roll I oh [ __ ] oh no no no no Stoneham
no no that's not cool
they just doing their job
not cool not cool you could have used a
tune or some [ __ ] like that I don't know
are we climbing this we are climbing yes
okay r2d2 ha ha ha ha
jokes they're funny because they're good
[ __ ] okay I'm really not used to always
say that but I don't know I just don't
play on expects this is not even an ex
back so I guess that's a problem [ __ ]
this focus pits can all the bros are
watching ok I can do this I know I can
what am I doing here
oh we're hiding nothing but rock she'd
never be able to make it up there but
that brat hey hey hey promise ring back
those goddamn dogs okay let's keep going
why they sell meat to the dogs in this
game I don't understand are we gonna get
caught I feel like there's gonna be
someone up there yep she could have just
hid out in the rocks there she didn't
have to climb up right away okay we're
not caught yet so many Jessica had so
much pain inside baby Danis all but I
really don't wanna get caught okay
we're day Hey it's my time hey lady how
you doin but I've been a shame if
something happened to you cars tires
know what visitor than their guns their
junk I don't know to hell she gets here
soon
I thought I used a nun to distract
people
what am I doing here that looks awesome
look at that [ __ ] that's so cool I
honestly wish hey hey hey hi AB drunk
Edward what's up
I wish game counter came out for the ps4
instead cuz cuz Quantic Dream wall is
like pushes the boundaries on on console
console gaming graphics in my opinion it
always look very stunning this game
looks amazing
no no doubt about it but it would be
cool to see on a ps4 what they could do
I bet there will do some demo I think
they did for ps3 no one gives a [ __ ]
hey yeah what the [ __ ] are you doing
Mike Mike that's crazy son of a [ __ ]
always up doing [ __ ] what I kept I press
eggs I spared
she's gonna take the bike my god this
just keeps getting better and better
hey Nagi okay
oh yeah baby
right doing anything okay
Oh
oh it drives himself that's cool are
they gonna come caps more caps is that
it damn damn
the spaceship what are we doing oh I
forgot to accelerate sorry about that
I thought it was accelerating by itself
just like life
just gets ahead of your son back
how are you going to escape a helicopter
if you're driving on a road
just go in the woods and you won't find
you geez am i right
no what was that
how is she still alive
roadblock Oh whatever you're us whatever
they whatever do whatever do whatever I
don't have to do anything oh [ __ ]
damn they really want my ass oh he's a
piece what you gonna do Jody come on no
choice no no I'm not
this is so badass
yeah yeah uh charge yes of course
gotta charge through the butt
damn girl what is that superpower he's
using hacks
robot tango we missed her
repeat we missed or she said it's a fake
attack yeah well yeah
seriously there's that many cops she's
not gonna get away don't get her
eventually right that was pretty bad as
though I I really liked that one
they really love rain in these Shay
Oh Shay seriously though Jody you can't
just drive into a town I'm sorry you
need a better plan
but we're [ __ ] now oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] all
snipers
I want to wanted us
right
how do they get faster than a motorbike
hey hey hey
why is she running from them what do
they make her do okay
well it's my time to party hey oh no
this car table flat except car it's car
[ __ ] okay sorry about that guy
whoa that kills someone awesome
what are you oh that's my bike cool you
gotta love the Lightning effects or
whatever it's in dope as hell let's take
care of this me first no I can't take
care of the sniper ah is your soul is
mine yeah another Mike another drunk
oh [ __ ] are you gonna kill him no way
Mike you crazy [ __ ]
all right about that that's not cool
just doing there get another one shows
up drunk at work what are the odds
what's going on what's happening what's
going on oh [ __ ] he just threw a nade
through a gas state Oh
well that's fireworks whoopsie I didn't
mean to do it
oh she killing them oh no are we
supposed to do huh I would run if I were
here oh [ __ ] sorry about that sorry
sorry sorry just give me one minute I'll
be right there
calm down jeez there you go
oh you're welcome
now what so anything else you need me
for how about a foot rub now fine
I don't have a foot vacation I promise
let's consider that
oh [ __ ] when you prevent them outside
okay table but I mean getting closer
yeah I'm trying but I don't know what
the [ __ ] do you want me to do
Oh fine to tell me Oh
O'Shea who's gonna be awesome okay okay
oh I guess things spun out of control
huh damn she made a mess that was
awesome
what's she gonna do oh [ __ ] is the main
mean soldier
- leave me the [ __ ] alone because next
time I'll kill everyone
oh yeah so I couldn't help but notice
she's wearing a bunch of dog tag to get
the message
I don't think she did that to make a
message I thought she did that just to
escape but this is my idea that's pretty
awesome I don't really like that I hope
you boys enjoyed as well this it looks
like a story is picking up I really like
it I'm actually gonna have to end an
episode here maybe like me enjoyed
watching hit subscribe and comment
birthday
I will see you brothers in the next one
stay awesome love you I'm trying